it's not the starter holiday anyone
would want these coach passengers have
waited hours to get to the ferry
terminal and there's more waiting ahead
after major delays LED Dover Pool to
declare a critical incident with
thousands of passengers stuck so we came
down here
and we were three and a half hours
waiting the passengers to be cleared and
they send you across in four or five
cultures at a time over to the main port
without as I say three and a half hours
and then by the time we reach the port
we joined a queue
and seven hours later we've moved about
three inches the port was teeming with
children and getting off the coaches to
go to the toilets if you went into the
toilet area it was devastated it was
full of bodies nobody could get their
enemies it was real heroin there have
been more coaches than the port
anticipated for the start of the Easter
break
some had to be diverted to truck stops
nearby to spend the night with
authorities saying delays are also down
to hold UPS by the French border control
but that's of little Comfort to a coach
load of teenagers who stripped a
football tournament was canceled because
of the wait there's so much traffic in
the area that they can't get people into
the terminal itself
the staff here are being very friendly
and helpful but what they're telling us
is that there is a real lack of French
border staff trying to get people
checked and into the terminal and while
the port has been as busy as this before
since the UK left the EU there are now
additional checks the difference of of
being in a post-brexit environment means
that every passport needs to be checked
before a vehicle or a passenger can
cross into the uh into the European
Union through France and that happens
here in Dover so it does make processing
more challenging bad weather also played
a part the port says but they are
hopeful they can clear the backlog over
the weekend once the coaches make it
here inside the terminal bought
authorities say that the weight is
getting shorter and shorter that these
passengers have already endured many
hours of discomfort stuck on board and
they're still hours away from their
destination
for some it will eat into precious
holiday time and while the port
apologized that may not be enough to
make up for all the time lost
Sky News Dover